[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec mgeen mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
burn out harcèlement horaires à rallonge
les internes en médecine vont mal on est
en fait dans une maltraitance
systématique organisé et accepter par
tous une souffrance accentuée par une
culture du silence qui plane sur le
milieu médical on a tellement peur et on
nous a tellement dit que si on parlait
de ce genre de choses on n'était pas
digne d'être médecin qu'on parle pas
cette situation pèse sur les internes
mais aussi sur les patients plus
susceptibles d’être victimes d'erreurs
liées à la fatigue
il y a personne qui monterait dans un
avion si on lui dit que le pilote il a
il a piloté pendant 18 ou 24 heures et
le lendemain il se propose de vous
amener à Paris alors comment mieux
prendre soin des étudiants en médecine
comme en briser l'omerta quand les
internautes c'est le thème de ce numéro
d'état de santé
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
émission d'état de santé qui compte est
allé ne serait-ce qu'une seule fois se
faire soigner à l'hôpital c'est
parfaitement que l'un des rouages
essentiels au fonctionnement précisément
du système de soins hospitaliers ce sont
les internes les jeunes médecins ils
représentent 40% du personnel soignant
or beaucoup d'entre eux souffrent ils
sont soumis à des cadences infernales et
ça n'est pas la seule raison pour
laquelle il souffre on va parler avec
vous docamine bonjour judokamine c'est
votre surnom sur les réseaux parce que
vous êtes ce qu'on appelle l'influenceur
santé vous avez créé effectivement un
Instagram vous avez 100000 abonnés sur
Instagram sur Twitter sur Facebook et
mais vous êtes médecin c'est pour ça que
vous êtes autorisé à en parler le
docteur Amina yari merci d'être avec
nous merci vous avez la gentillesse de
venir de Marseille vous êtes vous avez
terminé vous votre internat on va en
parler mais d'abord on s'arrête votre
portrait pourrait être santé
[Musique]
amine Ayari et médecin généraliste et
influenceurs santé plus connus sous le
nom de doc amine en 2017 alors qu'il est
encore externe à Marseille il lance le
compte et ça se dit médecin sur Facebook
Instagram et Twitter d'abord pour
raconter son quotidien d'internes à La
Timone avec humour puis petit à petit
pour faire de la vulgarisation médicale
et répondre au fake news désormais suivi
par près de 100 000 personnes il a
terminé son internat depuis quatre mois
il exerce actuellement dans un service
d'urgence à Marseille
[Musique]
votre compte sur Twitter est extrêmement
suivi parce que effectivement vous
racontez la vie interne ça a eu beaucoup
de succès pourquoi parce que les gens
avaient besoin de parler de témoigner
mais je pense que Jean s'identifie en
fait les gens s'identifient font des
liens entre eux qui ne sont pas seuls et
du coup bah ça agresse toute une
communauté autour de enfin de problèmes
communs de valeurs communes et aussi et
voilà je pense que vraiment les gens
s'identifient à ça quoi alors être
interne c'est pas une sinécure vous
venez de terminer vous votre internat en
médecine générale alors soit on est
interne en spécialité de médecine soit
on est interne en médecine générale
c'est pas la même durée d'ailleurs vous
avez passé en particulier un an et demi
à l'hôpital de la Timone à Marseille
pour votre internat c'est un mauvais
souvenir oui
oui honnêtement c'est mauvais souvenir
parce que
l'organisation n'est pas bonne parce que
heureusement qu'on avait le soutien des
équipes on avait des chefs qui étaient
qui étaient enfin voilà qui nous
soutenaient mais sinon en termes
d'organisation en termes de cadence en
terme de rythme en terme de moyens
c'était enfin c'est les conditions
dégradées tout le temps avec ou sans
covid c'est pas la période de covid qui
a fait que c'était dégradé vous nous
direz ce que c'est exactement ce qu'il y
a dans cette souffrance dont vous
témoignez mais déjà être interne c'est
vraiment un statut très particulier on
est à la fois en pleine formation et
médecin à part entière donc on donne des
soins on regarde l'infographie qui nous
explique quel est ce statut
[Musique]
encore étudiant et pourtant déjà en
poste à l'hôpital l'internat et le
passage obligé de tout médecin au bout
de 6 ans l'étudiant en médecine passe un
concours les épreuves classantes
nationales comme son nom l'indique en
fonction de leur classement et des
places disponibles les étudiants sont
orientés vers une spécialité et une
ville ils deviennent internes ils
enchaînent des stages de six mois dans
différents services la durée varie en
fonction de la spécialité par exemple il
faudra 3 ans avant d'être médecin
généraliste mais jusqu'à 6 ans pour être
chirurgien en parallèle les internes
continuent à suivre quelques cours
théoriques et doivent valider leur stage
le titre de docteur leur est délivré à
l'issue de l'internat après la
soutenance d'une thèse le statut
d'internes est celui de Praticien en
formation spécialisée en CDD ils
exercent en tant qu'agent public et sous
la responsabilité d'un médecin senior
comme tout salarié ils ont droit à 5
semaines de congés payés et sont générer
au SMIC la première année leur salaire
augmente ensuite progressivement passant
de 1539 euros brut mensuel la première
année jusqu'à 2256 euros la sixième
année les internes qui représentent
pourtant 40% du personnel médical ont
donc un statut bien particulier
[Musique]
alors donc la rémunération on y
reviendra parce que c'est une de vos
revendications
ce qui frappe quand on est interne on le
voit d'ailleurs dans la série Hippocrate
télévisée ça a été visé je sais pas si
vous avez pu la voir c'est les
responsabilités écrasantes qui sont
parfois sur les frères épaules de ces
jeunes internes qui n'ont pas encore
tout compris c'est à dire que en fait on
est jeune on avait entre 25 et 30 ans et
on est soumis constamment à la
souffrance aux émotions à la mort et
c'est vrai que quand on se retrouve à 25
ans avec la responsabilité des médecins
de pouvoir prescrire d'avoir une vie
entre nos mains passer des livres à la
pratique tout seul c'est un sacré poids
ouais alors vous avez l'habitude de dire
parfois que les internes c'est un peu
les bouche-trous de l'hôpital c'est pas
les bouches trop parce que sans les
internes l'hôpital ils tombent en panne
peut pas fonctionner donc c'est bien
plus que des bouche-trous bah en fait
c'est au début on les a utilisés comme
des bouche-trous et maintenant c'est
devenu des piliers quand je dis
bouche-trous c'est à dire que on utilise
pour faire un petit peu des tâches pour
lequel il n'y a pas de personnel ça peut
être du secretariat du brancardage alors
il y a pas de souci pour aider mais
c'est vrai que quand ça empiète sur
notre notre fonction principale de
médecin c'est un vrai sujet moi quand je
travaille à l'hôpital un tiers de mon
temps je le passais devant l'ordi et pas
devant les patients et il y a plein
d'autres choses comme ça quoi
par exemple en stage à l'hôpital dans
les hôpitaux privés il y avait une
personne dédiée à ça pour toutes les
urgences je l'appelais j'utilise j'ai
une besoin d'une place pour telle
patient il faut que tu me trouves une
place et ça me prenait 5 minutes au lieu
de me prendre deux heures alors on va
parler de tout ce qui dysfonctionne on
avait un peu esquissé mais on va le
reprendre mais je voudrais qu'on voit
d'abord le reportage de l'excès à
l'éperon parce qu'il est très fort le
témoignages d'une mère d'une interne qui
dit à quel point évidemment ça peut
aller loin
cette souffrance quand on est interne on
le regarde on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
le 2 mai 2019 Élise 24 ans met fin un
séjour de manière soudaine
[Musique]
ça c'était quand elle était externe donc
là elle avait 20 ans
elle était vraiment faite pour ce métier
alors
la mort de ma fille n'a aucun sens aucun
il y a des moments on a l'impression que
ça ne s'est pas produit quoi que c'est
pas possible
moi j'avais conscience qu'elle
travaillait trop et je ne cessais de le
lui dire au téléphone cela dit je ne
pensais pas que c'était à ce point parce
que si je l'avais su j'aurais pris le
premier TGV c'est clair
à l'hôpital
Élise enchaîne à l'égardes comme
beaucoup d'internes elle travaillait 70
à 90 heures par semaine
sans se plaindre lorsque vous cherchez à
comprendre en fait
parce que nous avions besoin de
comprendre et bah c'est difficile donc
il a fallu effectivement
se battre un petit peu
nous avons demandé à être reçu par la
direction de l'hôpital
nous avons rencontré l'ordre des
médecins nous avons eu beaucoup de
difficultés à recueillir les témoignages
des autres internes parce qu'ils avaient
peur
voilà
ils avaient peur d'être des conséquences
ils nous disent non non moi je ne peux
pas je ne veux pas parler je ne veux pas
témoigner parce que sinon je mon avenir
professionnel sera compromis c'est ça la
vérité
en raison de ce silence les chiffres
manquent certaines associations estiment
que 40% des internes souffriraient de
dépression
[Musique]
Laurence sa mère n'a pas voulu se taire
en mai 2020 elle fonde la lipsem une
association pour faciliter le dialogue
et la parole elle recueille sous
anonymat plusieurs témoignages d'un
terme la première année d'internat a été
la pire de ma vie c'est un mauvais
moment à passer
nous on est là 24 24 7 jours sur 7 il
faut que ça marche pour les gens et ça a
un coût un coup humain on est en fait
dans une maltraitance
systématique organisé et accepter par
tous qu'il y ait des suicides c'est
normal qu'il y ait du malaise c'est
normal qu'il y ait du burn-out c'est
normal qu'on travaille sans sans
garde-fou c'est normal qu'il y ait un
coup humain non parce que quand même
c'est normal et bien non moi je dis que
c'est totalement anormal
Olivia a vécu ce système de l'intérieur
un terme en médecine d'urgence elle
accepte de témoigner dans l'espoir de
faire bouger les choses
moi je travaillais
régulièrement plus de 26 jours d'affilée
j'ai fait plusieurs semaines à 96 heures
et je me souviens de ce jour où j'ai
débarqué en sanglots dans le bureau de
mon chef la semaine d'avant en interne
c'était suicidé et en fait moi je me
rendais compte que j'avais des idées
suicidaires et je vais voir mon chef
pour lui dire que j'allais très très mal
et que j'y arrivais plus et que je
savais plus comment faire mais que
j'avais vraiment l'impression que que
quelque chose qui allait pas mon chef
est resté de marbre et il m'a dit la
réanimation ça a toujours été un stage
difficile mais c'est un stage qui en
vaut la peine
le métier de médecin c'est quelque chose
que j'ai rêvé de faire toute ma vie
depuis que je suis toute petite je rêve
d'être docteur c'était c'est un
aboutissement pour moi d'être interne et
en fait le plus dur avec le burn out ça
a été que j'ai détesté mon travail et je
me suis mise à détesté une des choses
que j'aimais le plus dans ma vie et ça a
été extrêmement dur parce que j'ai dû
apprendre à me reconstruire complètement
en dehors de cette image
on a tellement peur et on nous a
tellement dit que si on parlait de ce
genre de choses on n'était pas digne
d'être médecin qu'on parle pas il y a
aucun autre métier où on travaille dans
les conditions avec lesquelles nous on
travaille on travaille sans fenêtre dans
nos bureaux on travaille dans des
bureaux qui sont pas échauffés mais
c'est pas grave parce que on n'est pas
tout à fait des êtres humains on est des
médecins on est des machines et on
survit à tout
aujourd'hui
Olivia va mieux elle a repris goût à son
travail
elle témoigne aussi pour se reconstruire
mais de nombreux internes n'osent pas
parler de leur mal-être en 2021 onze
internes se sont donnés la mort
[Musique]
docteur Ayari est-ce que vous vous avez
connu exactement des garçons et des
filles dans la même situation
psychologique
m'arrivée de rentrer chez moi et de
rentrer chez moi être pleurer il
m'arrivait de fin de me sentir seul de
d'avoir des envies quand je rentrais de
garde de donner un coup de volant pour
finir dans un dans un platane ça m'est
arrivé en fait enfin je sais que je suis
pas une situation isolée mais avant de
créer par exemple tout ce contenu sur
les réseaux sociaux je pensais pas que
ça avait une telle ampleur je reçois des
dizaines de messages par jour d'internes
pas seulement d'étudiants en médecine
d'externe qui sont qui ont des idées
suicidaires qui sont dépression qui
planent en rentrant chez eux le soir
c'est pas ça je pense qu'on forme pas
des bons médecins des gens qui sont
censés prendre soin des gens d'être
censés être bienveillants en les
maltraitant et en les poussant à bout
alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans cette
maltraitance en fait la maltraitance
et du harcèlement il y a du harcèlement
physique du harcèlement verbal parfois
du har sexuel est-ce que par exemple il
y a une espèce de culture de la
hiérarchie mais c'est ce que je fais que
on parle mal ou on maltraite verbalement
un interne l'hôpital c'est un système
très féodal très archaïque vous avez un
chef qui nomme des sous-chefs qui
eux-mêmes choisissent parmi les internes
donc en fait forcément nous on
aspiration c'est notre vocation c'est
notre métier on aspira on aspiration à
aller le plus loin possible dans votre
carrière forcément faut être bien vu par
la hiérarchie pour pouvoir grimper les
échelons donc c'est très compliqué et du
coup forcément on pense bien voir pour
bien se faire voir on a tendance de 1 à
pas raconter les choses mauvaises qui se
passent et de deux on raconte pas ces
difficultés
et puis il y a de la compétition donc
c'est à dire que quand vous avez moins
de postes de de poste par rapport au
nombre d'interne c'est un peu la
compétition entre les internes pour le
poste et il faut surtout pas montrer
signe de faiblesse parce qu'on se fait
rapidement écraser et ça cette
compétition là depuis la première année
de médecine chaque année on est classé
jusqu'au jusqu'au concours pour la
spécialité dans un contexte où on
affronte déjà la souffrance en
permanence on est obligé de garder pour
soi un certain nombre de difficultés
pour ne pas se mettre en difficulté par
rapport à la hiérarchie si on parle
on est pénalisé
on est brisé c'est vraiment ça
non non on est brisé et vu qu'on ne
s'est la personne au-dessus qui nous
fait monter ou pas si on commence à
dénoncer des comportements parfois
ignobles de harcèlement sexuel ou des
choses graves on est complètement brisé
on est complètement brisé mais ça des
exemples j'en ai j'en ai à l'appel j'en
ai à peine d'une amie qui se faisait
harceler sexuellement par un de ses
supérieurs et qui m'appelle en pleurs
donc j'étais au syndicat des internes
donc et je lui ai dit mais en fait c'est
du pénal ça faut porter plainte et moi
je dis ça très naïvement elle s'est
énervée contre moi et elle m'a dit mais
je fais quoi je balance 10 ans de
médecine à la poubelle ce mec qui me
brise ce mec il connaît tout le monde Je
j'arrête médecine en fait je pourrais
jamais être nommé nulle part
c'est ce qu'on voit aussi dans le
reportage réconcilarette parce que ce
qui est décrit c'est une espèce de
culture du surhum ou de la surface
c'est-à-dire que il faut être très très
fort parce que dans le fond elle va être
médecin ça se mérite faut souffrir pour
être médecin ça c'est ça existe encore
oui
et le pire c'est quand on se retrouve
moi ça m'avait personnellement quand on
raconte ça à des chefs et qui nous
disent mais tu sais moi mon époque on
n'avait pas le repos de sécurité moi mon
époque on faisait deux gardes d'affilée
non mais enfin je veux dire c'est des
des discours qui sont inadmissibles
c'est des discours de enfin moi mon
époque c'est le truc que chaque étudiant
en médecine a entendu au moins une fois
et qui nous renvoie à des époques
parfois qui n'ont même jamais existé
mais c'est vraiment ça c'est c'est donc
moi j'ai été maltraité donc il y a pas
de raison que voilà quoi que toi tu ne
sois pas exactement reproduit les
schémas est-ce que ça forme parce que le
but du système c'est de former les
futurs médecins qui seront évidemment
les meilleurs en fait si vous voulez moi
je pense personnellement je pense pas
qu'on forme des gens à l'empathie à la
bienveillance en les maltraitant
je pense pas qu'on forme un humain qui
est qui va être capable de recevoir une
plainte capable de comprendre une
souffrance en l'humiliant je pense pas
que ça marche comme ça le fond de sauce
je dirais de cette difficulté à vivre
c'est cette internat
c'est le rythme de travail
vous pouvez travailler jusqu'à 50 heures
vous avez vu des collègues 80 heures par
semaine
la loi n'est pas respectée
c'est tout simplement tout simple à dire
la loi n'est pas respectée c'est à dire
que le délai légal d'un interne c'est 48
heures alors je rappelle dans toute
façon générale c'est 35 pour un interne
c'est 48 et
pas forcément continue c'est 48 heures
dans la semaine quelles conséquence sur
les patients cette difficulté
moi je me suis vu devenir maltraitant
avec des gens parce qu'à 3h du matin
quand un patient vient c'est pas sa
faute attends je patiente c'est jamais
sa faute mais quand un patient vient
pour un motif
qui aurait pu attendre que moi je suis à
3h du matin je suis concrètement épuisé
ben je lui parle mal enfin j'insulte pas
mais je suis désagréable et je me suis
vu après je me rends compte et je vais
m'excuser très platement mais on en
arrive à devenir maltraitant on arrive à
faire des erreurs un copain qui est
chirurgien pédiatrique interne en
chirurgie pédiatrique qui me dit moi
enfin je vois flou je coupe des artères
et pour l'instant ça a toujours été
rattrapé parce qu'un senior et parce que
voilà personne n'en parle mais il me dit
un jour il y aura un drame et un jour
j'irai devant un juge vous l'avez dit
vous-même il y a une règle pour essayer
de limiter quand même le temps de
travail continu
voilà halte cadence infernal mais elle
est pas toujours facile à mettre en
place on va regarder le reportage avec
ça les parents qui a rencontré un chef
de service qui s'arrache les cheveux
mais qui finit par y arriver plus ou
moins reportage
[Musique]
à Marseille dans ce centre de lutte
contre le cancer un service a décidé de
changer les habitudes en s'attaquant au
temps de travail des internes cela passe
avant tout par un planning millimétré
vous voyez par exemple que Simon il a
deux jours offre que vous voyez ici
parce que là donc la veille de sa garde
il travaille pas le lendemain donc c'est
en repos de garde et au final sur les
six mois de présence on va équilibrer
les choses pour que ça ça arrive sur 48
heures par semaine imposé par la loi les
48 heures hebdomadaires sont rarement
respectés à l'hôpital mais pour ce
chirurgien c'était une évidence il y a
personne qui monterait dans un avion si
on lui dit que le pilote il a il a
piloté pendant 18 ou 24 heures et le
lendemain il se propose de vous amener à
Paris moi je me rappelle
particulièrement d'avoir fait des des
gardes où on faisait vendredi samedi
dimanche de garde et le lundi on
enchaîné sur
sur la journée normale j'ai jamais
trouvé que c'était intelligent voilà je
le lundi j'étais HS j'étais là parce
qu'il fallait être là mais j'ai toujours
trouvé que c'était complètement débile
alors comment cela fonctionne le service
contact actuellement cet interne présent
pour 6 mois comme six mois comme dans la
plupart des services une partie de son
travail consiste à remplir des papiers
des prescriptions et des comptes rendus
mais ici cette parade administrative
indispensable au fonctionnement du
service a été fortement réduite au
profit du temps passé au bloc opératoire
même si les internes ne sont pas
présents tous les jours le service doit
pouvoir tourner en leur absence d'un
côté les internes sont indispensables
mais de l'autre côté on peut pas non
plus faire reposer tout le
fonctionnement d'un système d'un service
hospitalier sur les épaules des
internautes désormais les 8 médecins
seniors du service se partagent les
tâches habituellement assurées par les
internes
comme lors de la visite quotidienne
tu
pour le docteur Maya cela veut dire un
peu plus de travail mais cela ne la
dérange pas pour nous ça paraissait à la
continuité en tout cas pour moi qui
avait été interne il y a très peu de
temps il y a beaucoup de choses où je me
disais mais c'est pas à moi de faire ça
je me sentais pas crédible dans
certaines tâches et donc je trouvais ça
tout à fait logique de les adapter et de
les faire moi une fois saignant pour pas
reproduire le même les mêmes
organisations qu'on avait vécu et mal
vécu côté interne il faut parfois un peu
de temps pour adhérer à cette nouvelle
organisation qui change de leurs
habitudes de travail
on voit bien que il y a une
frustration et et une réticence au
système c'est presque eux qui nous
disent finalement ce qu'on peut pas
venir plus souvent et finalement après
quand ils se rendent compte qu'il y a
beaucoup de cours qu'il y a beaucoup de
voilà qu'ils arrivent à s'organiser
différemment et puis à faire d'autres
choses à côté c'est vrai que à la fin du
semestre on a aucun interne qui nous dit
que finalement ils ont pas vu ça comme
quelque chose de positif
si ce système est plutôt bien accepté
dans le service en dehors de
l'établissement les médecins sont
souvent réticents à une application
stricte des 48 heures il y a deux
réactions la première c'est de dire que
dans leur service c'est pas possible ça
c'est
l'explication qui revient le plus
souvent et la deuxième c'est de dire que
les internes vont être mal formés voilà
et que donc
presque c'est altruiste de dire il moi
je le fais pas parce que comme ça je
forme bien mes internes
aujourd'hui plusieurs associations
d'internes réclament un décompte du
temps de travail qui permettrait de se
rapprocher des 48 heures légales pour
l'instant le fonctionnement du
professeur Turini reste une exception
dans les hôpitaux
[Musique]
alors on voit que ce chef de service
effectivement il est obligé cela dit de
faire appel à ses collègues qui doivent
travailler davantage pour alléger les
horaires des vertueux et c'est compliqué
mais c'est compliqué et ça c'est pas
généralisé c'est absolument pas
généralisé un de mes premiers stages
d'internat c'était dans cet
établissement institut pas obligé donc
j'étais dans le service d'un service des
urgences donc c'est un service où il y a
des patients quand même grave très grave
et pourtant on arrivait à font respecter
le délai légal sur la rémunération
maintenant est-ce que vous estimez que
étant étudiant quoique opérationnel
auprès des malades c'est suffisant quand
on interne on est payant forfait peu
importe l'ombre d'heures qu'on fait on
est payé la même chose on a
une majoration pour chaque garde les
gardes comptent en plus mais sinon pour
chaque heure regarde qu'on fait on est
payé exactement la même chose donc c'est
à dire qu'on fasse 50 ou qu'un inter par
exemple en neurochirurgie en phase 80
c'est exactement la même chose ce qui
fait que par exemple pour l'interne qui
fait 80 son taux de rémunération horaire
est beaucoup plus faible que celui qui
en fait qui en fait 50 donc ne serait-ce
qu'en réduisant parfois le temps de
travail on peut augmenter la
rémunération horaire et déjà en fait ça
ferait déjà du bien à tout le monde non
on ne demande pas des milliers
d'essences en fait la revendication
principale c'est juste que la loi soit
respectée vous avez été dégoûté ou le
métier comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure
dans le repas est-ce qu'il y a un moment
vous êtes dit bon je fais autre chose
parfois des concours qui n'ont rien à
voir je me suis inscrit au concours pour
être gendarme rien à voir oui oui
vraiment je suis inscrit au concours
pour devenir pilote d'avion
depuis toujours la médecine on peut pas
faire médecine sans avoir cette vocation
chevillée au corps pour en arriver au
point de dégoûter des gens passionnés
faut vraiment y aller fort quoi
longtemps les internes ont subi et vous
ne sentez pas que il y a un petit
mouvement de prise de conscience qui
fait que il y a eu un Ségur de la santé
il y a eu des moyens qui ont été très
bien non c'est très bien je crache pas
dessus c'est dur de la santé c'est très
bien mais c'est très difficile je pense
pour le gouvernement actuel de rattraper
30 ans en fait parce que ça tout à fait
enfin ces sujets on en parle moi j'étais
en première année de médecine et
j'entendais déjà et j'entendais les
internes parler déjà de on aurait pu
faire cette émission il y a 20 ans donc
pour vous dire à quel point en fait
c'est quelque chose qui qu'on a laissé
pourrir parce que au final ça tenait à
peu près voilà tu vois il y avait pas
trop de de enfin pas trop de lumière
là-dessus et enfin voilà et la copine
évidemment et la covid a tout fait ouais
exactement et maintenant donc vous êtes
aux
urgences médecins généralistes
aussi peut-être un jour en cabinet
peut-être merci infiniment merci Docteur
Ayari dokamine sur les réseaux merci
d'être venu nous parler de des
difficultés des internes c'était
important et à très vite pour un
prochain numéro d'état de santé
[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec mgeen mutuelle santé prévoyance
vous a présenté état de santé
[Musique]